oh this is cute
what do you guys just playing with your
dolls here a little fight scene going on
is it a little choreograph kind of setup
who's this guy
Berlin techno rave is just enrolled in
from 3 a.m.
interesting there's no for toy been here
and that on purpose or the Bruce oh yeah
sure I heard that before
the civil civil war no thought well
they'll do and stand around kind of
important at each other look at me I'm
an idiot tell you what would really
happen if there was a fight between all
of us basically go a little bit like
this just got hit over there and look at
me I'm Captain America I got smashed
over there like a little fly he's just a
kid he can fall over he's not even real
guns guns are cool so you can hop off
the table bunch of losers these guys a
lot of those guys they can stay and you
can come with me because we're now mates
so thanks for nothing before creation
itself
there were six singularities forged into
Infinity stones
this is our first day here we are in
Pinewood in Atlanta and it's it's
actually pretty unbelievable day one of
what promises to be a year of fun-filled
lensing I remember actually gonna see
the first Avengers with one of my best
mates from home and I'd never have
dreamed that I'd ever be in one of these
movies let alone playing spider-man I
feel like I'm on top of the world
because this is just mind-blowing
what we always try to do at marvel
studios is we're building the cinematic
universe is look at the big picture how
can things relate across movies and
across years Avengers infinity war is
the culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe as started in May of
2008 with a release of Iron Man 1 and it
really is an unprecedented culmination
of a series of films interlinked
together which it's time had never been
done before and for us the important
thing is making it all come together we
know they're gonna face phantoms we've
been setting that up since Avengers 1
how do you do that in a way that is
unexpected that hits the Avengers
against somebody who's more powerful
than any when they faced and yet make
them completely unprepared to face them
well tear them apart which is why we did
Civil War before infinity war as we were
conceiving and executing Civil War the
end of that movie was very much a setup
for what these movies would be we always
had this sense of that
tony is not talking to Steve the
Avengers are basically a name with
nobody in it the world is vulnerable
Tony senses his greater threat
approaching and so he is doing
everything in his power to keep the
earth safe
thanos shows us why he's the biggest the
best the baddest villain that we've ever
had and the most frightening villain of
the avengers have ever faced the most
exciting part is the incredible roster
of well developed characters and it's
going to create a really combustible
exciting massive scale adventure you
know that we're onto something within
the studio when we hit upon an idea or
we see a piece of concept art and all of
us in the room go this is cool and an
Avengers infinity war Avengers
we'll need the guardians of the galaxy
because of what Marvel is because of
what they have done over the last ten
years
these next two Avengers films will be an
event like no one has ever seen on film
before
[Music]
[Music]